hear that that's the sound of the mantis
shrimp striking metal but it's fearsome
face hammers yeah face hammers weird but
then again the mantis shrimp isn't
actually a shrimp
it's a stomatopod and an ordinary one at
that they use those face hammers to blow
prey like clams and crabs to pieces they
also use them to fight other mantis
shrimp for housing it's a lot like the
techies in San Francisco only with more
legs
I guess researchers at Duke University
recently set up a little mantis Fight
Club to understand how these little
pugilist scrapped it out mantis shrimp
like a lot of animals first do a lot of
posturing in this case waving their arms
around but in almost every contest that
end up throwing down to avoid injury
they strike each other in a very
specific spot a tail plate called a
telson this acts as a punching bag to
absorb the tremendous energy so we
thought that the winners of the contest
would be the ones that struck with a
greater force but we actually found that
in your strikes and grade the number of
times the researchers think this
communicates their aggression and
persistence to the loser who mopes away
so the next time you're at an open house
try punching your rivals and that tuchus
you make a mantis shrimp crowd